une jeune dame m'a posé les questions
suivantes quel a été l'élément
déclencheur pour démarrer une telle
entreprise
avez vous un enfant handicapé
je lui ai dit non un membre de votre
famille handicapé alors non plus alors
il me dit ceci je n'arrive pas à
comprendre votre motivation à travailler
avec toutes ces personnes handicapés et
en difficulté d'apprentissage
me voilà donc à lui confier ce qui suit
en ou 2003 un médecin m'annonce le
diagnostic
j'avais une tumeur à la gorge
complètement bouleversé par cette
nouvelle d'autant plus que je venais de
perdre mon père quelques mois auparavant
d'un cancer pendant les soins palliatifs
avec papa à un certain moment donné ma
demande et elaine hess qui étaient déjà
arrivés à poser la question pourquoi ils
ont mis cela en une tumeur j'ai dit non
pas alors il m'a dit écoute moi bien ma
fille si un jour on annonce une telle
nouvelle
eh bien je meurs profondément
déstabilisé par la peur la peur de
mourir
j'ai décidé de mordre dedans j'ai décidé
d'aller de l'avant
à travers un jeune dans cette démarche
en espérant le retour à la santé j'ai
vite compris que le silence faisait
partie du processus et que réfléchie
et l activité principale toute ma vie se
repasser dans mon esprit et c'est à ce
moment que j'ai réalisé à quel point
j'aurais voulu travailler avec les
personnes démunies et c'est aussi à ce
moment que j'ai pris conscience que si
je ne m'en sortais pas j'aurais vraiment
le sentiment de ne pas avoir su faire la
différence de ne pas avoir su utiliser
mes talents pour faire ce qui me tenait
tant à coeur à aider mais comment
comment aider lorsque j'ai un diplôme
universitaire en relations industrielles
et toute mon expérience et dans le
domaine des ressources humaines
je me suis dit peut-être que je pourrais
devenir une travailleuse de rue jusqu'à
ce que le silence me révèle l'essentiel
à aider les démunis sur le plan des
apprentissages et de l'emploi alors je
sentais que je détenais quelque chose
que je détenais le commun utilisé mes
compétences et les mettre au service des
personnes démunies que je détenais le
moyen pour mettre en cohérence les
valeurs que je porte est allé dans
l'action pour poser des gestes qui
allait faire la différence mais encore
une fois c'est dit mme unis lesquelles
la réponse à mon réveil de la chirurgie
lorsque je me suis retrouvé la moitié du
visage paralysé tel choc
oh mais attention pas seulement là
parisi mais surtout le regard des gens
sur mon handicap je réalisais qu'on ne
voyait plus qu'on ne voyait que mon
handicap et à ce moment je me disais ce
qui se passe on devient aveugle face à
un homme a un handicap et on oublie que
derrière cet état se cache un potentiel
à découvrir et
loin des limitations qu'on imagine je
vous reviens avec ma jeune dame du début
lorsqu'elle a compris que finalement la
personne handicapée
c'était moi elle m'a dit vous savez
madame maintenant je comprends saisi
l'ampleur de votre engagement dans cette
cause qui vous tient tant à coeur
voilà donc d'où vient cette
détermination inébranlable à mettre sur
pied une entreprise permettant le
développement de jeunes en difficulté
d'apprentissage
on passe maintenant à l'action du rêve à
la réalité
je plonge je dans le vide pleinement
engagés optimiste je plonge encore une
fois dans le vide mais le vide de
service à mon dieu je vous et vous il
faut non seulement voir autrement pour
faire face à cette situation mais il
faut également penser et agir autrement
un réflexe solidaire était nécessaire
pour bâtir le filet de sécurité
sous ces personnes les plus vulnérables
de notre société
imaginez une usine où le travail devient
l'outil de formation un milieu de
travail permettant l'exploration
professionnels pour qu'ils puissent
découvrir leurs intérêts et talent un
espace de collaboration ou différents
spécialistes circulent au moment
opportun dans le cheminement de la
personne là où nous soulignons les bons
ou nous soulignons les progrès un
environnement où nous abordons même le
travail avec humour là
où l'erreur fait partie de l'expérience
et où le plus petit pas est un pas dans
la bonne direction
bref un milieu de vie où il est possible
d'apprendre autrement pour soutenir
leurs efforts au quotidien
il nous fallait une action musclée
la formation de nouvelles solidarités
un partenariat privé public s'est mise
en place dès le jour leur réseau
scolaire collaborent et le réseau des
affaires sociales emboîte le pas
rapidement de sorte que différents
spécialistes contribue au bon moment et
on parle ici d'enseignants de
conseillers pédagogiques de travailleurs
sociaux d'éducateurs spécialisés de
coordonnateur au développement des
compétences pratiques même deux
psychologues tous en support aux
apprentissages de nos jeunes
sincèrement pour réussir à obtenir un
tel réseau intégré de services
je pourrais vous communiquer que c'était
le véritable défi de toute notre
histoire
maintenant comment ça se passe le
développement des jeunes dans notre
milieu êtes d'accord avec moi que la
majorité des choses que l'on apprend
dans les vies se fait par la répétition
alors apprendre par la pratique
voici un projet d'apprentissage
relativement complexe une antenne de
grue
c'est dans le secteur électrique
électronique qu'on fabrique ses antennes
sa vie
lorsque je suis arrivé avec un projet
comme ça j'ai eu à nos partenaires
c'est à dire un manque de nos
partenaires qui veut voir puis m'a dit
bon lot et le nom ce exagère le défi est
beaucoup trop compliqué pour le jeune
quand moi j'ai entendu ça je me disais
mais voyons le défi autant pour eux pour
nous c'est ce qui nous garde en contact
avec nos capacités ce qui nous garde en
contact avec nos ressources et c'est ce
qui nous permet de nous développer
vous savez ce qui est intéressant avec
toutes leurs structures qu'on a
maintenant en place c'est que toute une
dynamique multidisciplinaire je n'ai pas
leur père a dream je n'ai pas la même
formation et je vois autrement ma vision
des choses je considère le potentiel et
non les limitations
je vous présente à l'écran lé en fait
l'outil de travail que le client nous a
transféré pour faire l'antenne de grues
du début
maintenant voici l'outil que nous avons
développé notre préoccupation constante
rendre accessible l'apprentissage
pour y arriver nous devons décortiqué à
sa plus simple expression l'ensemble des
projets et permettent à une personne par
exemple qui est en mesure seulement de
couper mais qu'ils puissent participer
contribuer dans la fabrication du
produit est fier de le faire vous avez
notre recherche et développement est
toujours dans un vide de service et
toujours on est toujours en innovation
dans cette activité
face au vide de services auxquels on
fait face il n'existe aucun programme
à ma connaissance pour ce genre de
recherche développement ici voir
autrement signifie dépasser les
handicaps dans tous les sens du mot voir
autrement
c'est voir le développement humain que
l'on touche comme du développement
durable pour notre société
parlons maintenant de résultat ici si le
but est ce que je pourrais vous dire
c'est le bulletin de notre client c'est
un outil de qualité
alors ça c'est la récompense qu'on
obtient suite aux efforts qu'on fait
pour décortiquer toutes les opérations
alors pour nos clients il s'agit d'un
service et pouvait contrôler et efficace
fait en sorte que nos clients sont
fidèles
maintenant parlons du résultat pour nos
jeunes nos jeunes qui sont à leur rythme
au niveau des apprentissages meilleure
capacité d'adaptation augmentation de la
confiance en soi et de l'estimé de soi
sont les clés de la réussite est le
moteur de la motivation à
l'apprentissage
la beauté de tout le processus et de
cette démarche c'est que lorsque la
personne est en mesure de réaliser
l'ensemble d'un projet qualifiant elle
obtient soit une attestation ou un
diplôme en médecine semi spécialisés
métier reconnue par le ministère de
l'éducation
nous offrons donc la possibilité de
réussir autrement
nous sommes toujours orienté sur les
possibles et là je vous racontais m6
exemple qui nous est arrivé à un certain
moment donné on nous a référé
un jeune homme de l'extérieur dans son
milieu étant donné ses difficultés
on lui avait montré à étiqueter des
boîtes de conserve
il est arrivé chez nous au volant de sa
voiture tout de suite
nous avons remarqué qu'il pouvait avoir
des capacités très différente
aujourd'hui
ce jeune homme est intégré dans une
entreprise de la région comme
manutentionnaire et opérateurs de
chariots élévateurs avec ses cartes de
compétence imaginez maintenant son
avenir nous travaillons avec le réseau
scolaire dans une démarche de
développement de compétences pratiques
et de programmes reconnus par le
ministère de l'éducation vous demanderai
de prendre quelques secondes et de
regarder l'expression du visage de ce
jeune homme regardez à quel point vous
pouvez lire toute sa fierté
imaginez maintenant tout ce que l'on
peut observer en cours de route
leur courage leur ténacité et leur
volonté d'y arriver est de réussir
vous n'avez pas idée des efforts qu'ils
mettent de la confiance en soi qui
s'installe au fur et à mesure qu'ils
prennent confiance en leurs moyens et
des sourires que l'on voit apparaître
lors ce qu'ils y arrivent
imaginez l'impact sur les jeunes sur
l'espoir des parents sur lie dans nos
écoles sur l'aide à nos entreprises
une formule où tout le monde y gagne une
formule de soutien et d'entre aide ma
foi en ses jeunes
ma foi en l'importance de créer un tel
concept innovateur sur le plan social
était plus forte que les obstacles posés
sur ma route
j'ai appris à jongler avec deux
développements en même temps le
développement des affaires où j'avais
toujours à coeur de décrocher des
projets de sous traitance qualifiant
pour les jeunes et le développement du
concept de cette approche
qui est devenu aujourd'hui une force
motrice pour notre organisation
neuf ans d'efforts en collaboration avec
mes partenaires
notre organisation est devenue un outil
un milieu de travail qui donne du sens à
ceux qui sont en difficulté scolaire et
du sens à ce qui autrefois étaient
placés en institution
l'impact sur les jeunes sommes mesure
même physiquement leurs regards qui se
transforme et s'illumine lorsqu'ils
prennent confiance en eux
les sourires qui nous parlent et des
gestes qui nous touchent la fois de
réalité m'amène à un constat malgré neuf
ans d'efforts nous faisons toujours face
à un vide de service ce vide ayant comme
impact d'abandonner deux jeunes
personnes vulnérables ayant le potentiel
d'apprendre et de réussir si ma jeune
dame du début faisait partie des
décideurs d'aujourd'hui et que les tice
elle était ici avec nous dans cette
salle j'aurai à mon tour une question à
lui poser marché redonne à la lumière de
ce que je viens de vous démontrer
comment imaginez vous la suite
merci